we've been talking about it we've been  promising it all week long and now the  time is here that's right please give it  up for the dance  of Melbourne Brisbane  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  the dancing greatest loves you over that  we're celebrating  Hanukkah the holiday season all morning  long here on Good Day Las Vegas more  energy for this time  that's not Natural Energy uh if you  missed this performance and how could  you have you can see the dancing  griddles everywhere right all over uh  Southern Nevada there's a lighting  ceremony of the menorah Clark County  Government Center today at five o'clock  how do you guys do this all Hanukkah  long all holiday season my goodness it's  a Hanukkah Miracle hey  all right 6 47 here thank you gentlemen  for being here I appreciate that and  happy Hanukkah audio thank you for  having me